bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat les lois sont mieux
appliquées c'est ce que le sénat a
constaté dans un rapport rendu public la
semaine dernière
il faut dire qu'au 31 décembre 2011 64 %
des lois votées par le parlement était
appliquée contre 20% seulement l'année
précédente
pour cela le sénat a créé une toute
nouvelle commission la commission de
suivi de l'application des lois elle va
d'ailleurs planché sur cette loi en
particulier à savoir les lois grenelle 1
et 2 ou encore la loi dalo sur le droit
au logement opposable
alors pourquoi ces lois sont elles mieux
appliquer peut-on encore améliorer les
choses tout de suite je vous propose de
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle pour
suivre un débat sur ce thème très belle
séance à tous monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la séance et reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
rapport annuel du contrôle de
l'application des lois à la demande de
la commission sénatoriale pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois et la
parole est à monsieur david assouline
président de la commission sénatoriale
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois de la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
si pour la première fois dans ces
conditions c'était demandé l'année
dernière pour la première fois par un
drop mais de façon instituée par notre
institution
le sénat que se produit un débat en
séance plénière sur le rapport annuel
c'est que l'application des lois au delà
de tout technicité de toute approche
partisane est un enjeu démocratique
majeur la loi fondent à soi irrigue la
république
l'institution comme la somme d'individus
qu'elle organise en créant des esgaulx
la loi cimenté justifie notre société
dès lors sa fabrique doit être exigeante
sur vérifiées et vérifiables et ce du
début à la fin du processus
depuis ses premières élaboration dans
les cabinets ministériels ou les bureaux
du parlement jusqu'aux quartiers de nos
villes et les campagnes nos territoires
où elles s'appliquent
la première condition de notre égalité
républicaine et l'effectivité de la loi
notre premier dessin doit donc être
l'infaillibilité même relative mais la
recherche de cette infaillibilité de
cette effectivité
si la loi dans son esprit ou dans sa
lettre n'est pas appliquée faute de
directives réglementaires de moyens
humains institutionnels ou matériels
alors le lien qui unit les citoyens à
leurs représentants alors parlement est
abîmée et par conséquent c'est le lien
qui relie les citoyens aux autres
citoyens qui est affecté également ainsi
veiller à la mise en application des
lois dépasse grandement les objectifs
pourtant essentiel de simples et
pourtant nécessaire stabilité et
sécurité juridiques d'équilibré entre le
législatif et l'exécutif
ou même de cohérence entre les paroles
et les actes des dirigeants politiques
veiller à la mise en application des
lois est un élément de restauration de
la confiance des citoyens dans la loi
dans la politique en général et ce
faisant un élément de restauration de la
confiance des citoyens dans leur volonté
même de vivre ensemble dans son traité
du gouvernement civil
le philosophe anglais john locke était
sans équivoque je le cite il n'est pas
toujours nécessaire de faire des lois
mais il est toujours il est toujours
nécessaire de faire exécuter celles qui
ont été faites
voilà ce à quoi nous allons nous atteler
d'évidence l'application des lois dans
sa dimension réglementaire est une
discipline complexe et juridique
néanmoins pour pas veut parvenir à
l'envisager dans sa globalité
ce sont des questions simples qui
doivent nous guider
la loi est-elle appliquée
sinon pourquoi où sont les blocages
comment les résoudre
si elle est appliquée les effets
recherchés sont ils ceux obtenus
répond-t-il aux besoins ciblés les
moyens programmées ont ils été apportée
suffit style sans sombrer dans
libération peut-on améliorer le
dispositif
en d'autres termes le contrôle de
l'application des lois doit évaluer la
loi un lot de la réalité et du terrain
concernant le bilan qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui pour l'année 2010-2011 des
33 loi requérant un suivi réglementaire
8 soit 24 % ont reçu l'intégralité de
leurs textes d'application 21 64 % sont
partiellement mise en application et 4
12% à tant de la totalité de leurs
décrets
s'agissant de la législature la
treizième dans son ensemble 59% des cent
trente et une loi promulguée
nécessitant des décrets d'application
sont totalement appliquée
37% le sou partiellement et 3 ne le sont
pas du tout monsieur le ministre à
propos de ce bilan chiffré
une ré une remarque en réalité presque
un rappel à ce qu'il était convenu de
faire ensemble pour éviter les
malentendus de l'année dernière en effet
il avait été convenu qu'en entre votre
ministère et les services du sénat que
la période considérée pour établir ce
bilan annuel s'arrêterait au 31 décembre
or si notre apport respecte dans ces
données dans ces schistes et dans ses
conclusions cet accord tacite on va dire
votre communication solennelle en
conseil des ministres ainsi que vos
interventions dans la presse annonce des
chiffres qui portent au 31 janvier 2012
je comprends la précipitation d'une fin
de législature et votre ardeur à vouloir
rattraper le retard accumulé
parfois par vos prédécesseurs mais à
l'avenir il serait bienvenu d'en rester
à des bases communes
comment comparer les pointages de la
haute assemblée se de votre ministère si
ce dernier ne respecte pas les bornes
qui avaient été arrêtés d'ailleurs cet
épisode mais drastiquement lumière
l'urgence qu'il y a harmonisé encore
plus que cela les bases de données de
votre ministère et du sénat c'est une
demande officielle de notre part les
tableaux de bord de suivi de la mise en
application des lois devrait être
transmis au sénat
à mon avis spontanément sont que nous
ayons à voulait quémander et en temps
réel
monsieur le ministre vous prêt à prendre
cet engagement aujourd'hui je jeudi à
l'assemblée à la haute assemblée
de quoi il s'agit exactement bien
entendu quand un décret publié nous
l'avons en temps réel c'est le journal
officiel cdj franchement mais le
processus de suivi que vous maîtrisez
puisque c'est comme ça que vous booster
vos propres
collègues ministres vous leur dites il
est tel décret est enlisé au conseil
d'état ou dentelle administration pouvez
vous agir c'est comme cela que vous
agissez nous avons besoin de savoir d
créé par décret ou il en est à quelle
étape pour jouer notre propre rôle de
pression de demandes de d'accélération
de telle ou telle administration parce
que c'est la condition pour jouer notre
rôle indépendant de contrôle et de ne
pas être uniquement sujet à ce que vous
faites et des résultats de ce que vous
faites
car nous contrôlons dans cette histoire
l'exécutif ne sommes pas une espèce de
deux de contrôleurs après coup de ce qui
a été fait de même et pour en finir avec
la question des dates à considérer notre
commission recommande donc on vous le
redit que l'objectif des six mois que
vous avez posé pour évaluer la rapidité
pour gros que les décrets soient
publiées dans les six mois
c'est l'objectif du premier ministre que
vous avez réaffirmé les dates à choisir
seraient mieux venus si c'était ou
correspondance avec le calendrier
parlementaire c'est-à-dire 30 septembre
et 31 mars plutôt que au sein juin et 31
décembre qui ne correspondent pas
complètement à notre propre calendrier
de cessions cela étant et si un examen
plus détaillé de ces chiffres révèlent
réveillerez le caractère en partie
optique de cette consolidation
je vous accorde volontiers qu'il s'agit
votre rapport
beau résultat d'une amélioration
significative la création du comité de
suivi la régulation que vous avez
entrepris réunion interministérielle la
nomination d'un commissaire à
l'application des lois ou encore
l'incitation à tenir le délai de six
mois sont autant d'initiatives qui ont
sans aucun doute pesé dans ce résultat
admettez avec moi que le parlement a
contribué à cette amélioration
les douze rapports de l'assemblée
nationale les questions écrites ou
orales au gouvernement les débats en
semaine de contrôle la création même de
la commission sénatoriale de contrôle de
l'application des lois
participent également de ce bon résultat
pour cette année
toutefois malgré cette avance et je le
répète significative je ne vois pas ici
de motif à verser trop dans le
triomphalisme
d'abord c'est mauvais même quand on a
des bons résultats parce qu on
démobilise mais à l'aune de ce qu'il
faudrait nous sommes encore loin du
compte
quand on était à 20% d'applications
passé à 64 c'est pas mal mais quand
l'objectif est de 100 pour cent
soixante-quatre c'est insuffisant
l'objectif principal à savoir la
publication des décrets dans un délai de
six mois après l'adoption de la loi
demeure très insuffisant à 42% très loin
de l'objectif de 100% que s'est fixé le
gouvernement
si je vous vois interloqué alors je
précise vous vous êtes dans l'objectif
fixé que tous les décrets soient
publiées dans les six mois
40% des lois ou eu leur décret dans les
six mois vous pouvez dire que sur la
législature sur cette année écoulée ou
sur les cinq années écoulées
vous arrivez à 80% dans les six mois
il n'y a eu que 40% et donc c'est
forcément insuffisant par rapport à
l'objectif fixé
le rattrapage sur les lois les plus
anciennes semble maintenant un peu
stagné
la remise des rapports du gouvernement
au parlement s'avère franchement
défectueuse pour une large majorité ne
sont tout simplement pas remis quand ils
le sont c'est hors délai et d'une
précision disons assez aléatoire jeu je
l'avais montré au secrétaire général du
gouvernement
deux exemples un rapport en si lyn quel
décret publié tel décret n'est pas
publié pour notre information ça faisait
peu
les vrais rapports conséquent qui nous
éclairait je ne rentrerai pas dans la
veine discussions pour tenter de savoir
si trop de ces rapports sont commandés
au gouvernement ils sont inscrits dans
la loi ils doivent être réalisés cela
c'est pour répondre à l'argument de ceux
qui disent oui mais c'est de votre faute
parlementaires à chaque fois dans les
débats sur les lois vous demander des
rapports alors vous étonnez pas
qu'ensuite il y en a tellement qu'on ne
voit jamais sortir à partir du moment où
le ministre accepte et que c'est voté
par l'assemblée le rapport doit être là
on n'a pas cherché la libye sur ce
serait la cause
viendrait de nous mêmes qui les avons
demandé bien
enfin sur le qualitatif le chantier est
immense les élus de tout bord témoigne
très fréquemment le décret d'application
au mieux difficile au pire au contraire
à l'objet de la loi
on a même trouvé un des décrets
d'application des directives et
circulaires préfectoral qui ont modifié
l'application de la loi qui ont poussé
le législateur à devoir modifier la loi
pour qu'il s'adapte à ce que le préfet
avait mis en place et qu'ils n'étaient
plus bougea bon ça c'est l'extrême
l'extrême neigeux je vous sortirait dans
le rapport auscitains un tel cas je
laisse aux soins que chaque président
bien sûr la présentation des
propositions de sa commission pour
revenir aux autres recommandations de la
commission sénatoriale chargée du
contrôle de l'application des lois une
meilleure préparation des loin en amont
avec des études d'impact approfondie
hélas non systématique dès le dépôt des
projets doit du nombre de la nature des
mesures réglementaires envisagées en
aval la sortie des lois du parlement ne
doit plus être comprise comme le terme
du processus démocratique de leur
conception mais bien comme le début du
compte à rebours de leur mise en
application la plus rapide et la plus
fidèle possible à propos des rapports
nous estimons comme pour les mesures
réglementaires qu'un délai raisonnable
devrait être fixé cela étant je
n'entends attablés personnes la
réflexion sur la production législative
depuis les études d'impact jusqu'à la
publication des décrets de va être menée
tant au gouvernement qu'au parlement et
sur toutes les travées de cette
assemblée de tous les bords politiques
il y a beaucoup à faire ensemble
en la matière il est une idée reçue qui
persistent à juste titre notre pays est
atteint d'une forme insidieuse
d'installation législatives le nombre de
lois votées chaque année reste
relativement stable
là n'est pas le problème n'arrête pas
nous dire y'a trop de lois c'est pas
vrai y'a pas plus de lois qu'avant mais
le nombre de lois votées chaque année
donc qui reste stable le nombre de
dispositions dans chaque loi a
littéralement explosé en 90 une loi
comportait en moyenne 22 articles 33
arctique en 2041 2009 on voit bien la
progression qui devient exponentielle de
même comme nous l'a fait remarquer le
secrétaire général du gouvernement
monsieur serge lavigne lors de son
audition du 9 janvier en 2010 un projet
une proposition de loi déposée au
parlement avec 18 articles étaient au
final adopté avec 37 articles passant
ainsi de 6000 à douze mille mots
constatant cette dangereuse évolution
monsieur la ville s'est autorisé un
verdict sans appel nos lois sont à la
fois lourde et imprécis je ne partage
pas complètement ce verdict
d'autant que si la loi arrive au
parlement c'est que le parlement peut
l'améliorer et l'enrichir
ça signifie parfois plus d'articles plus
de mots
ça pourrait être un peu plus souvent
l'apport du parlement viendrait
remplacer dédé des articles et pas
seulement s'ajouter ça serait
certainement plus productifs mais il ne
faudrait pas comprendre ce que je dis je
partage
il ya explosion des textes de longueur
des textes il faudrait pas le prendre
comme la bonne
façon de répondre à ce problème c'est de
manger tout cuit ce qui nous arrive ray
comme projets gouvernementaux puisque
l'essentiel des textes viennent du
gouvernement et nous on n'aurait plus
qu'à acté devant l'ampleur de la tâche à
accomplir
monsieur le ministre je vous le dis
comme de le dire et un veau successeur
probable
nous serons extrêmement vigilants et
proactif quant à la publication des
décrets d arrêter et même les
circulaires temps sur les délais que sur
le fond mais l'activité de notre
commission ne saurait se résumer au
pointage à la vérification des textes
opérant la mise en application de la loi
la commission sénatoriale chargée du
contrôle de l'application des lois ne
saurait être une banale agence potable
ni une quelconque police des décrets
notre mandat quand notre ambitieux vont
bien au delà si notre commission dépend
d'une instruction générale du bureau du
sénat
pour son fonctionnement notre mandat
comme notre ambition s'enracine dans la
constitution dans les trois principes
que son article 24 énonce le parlement
vote la loi il contrôler l'action du
gouvernement
il évalue les pratiques publiques c'est
dans ces trois domaines que dorénavant
nous poursuivons avec un programme qui
va s'étaler sur l'année de contrôle de
l'application des lois dans plusieurs
domaines notamment des lois
emblématiques dont je parlerai dans les
conclusions que nous allons vrai et donc
l'année prochaine
le rapport que je vous ai présenté ne
sera pas seulement un rapport
statistique et quantitatif mais
intégrera le travail qualitatif de tous
nous rapporteur merci de votre attention
merci monsieur le président la pâte la
parole est à monsieur patrick ollier
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission de contrôle
de l'application des lois
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier le sénat et
en particulier sa nouvelle commission de
contrôle l'application des lois et
monsieur david assouline son président
de me donner l'occasion d'établir
aujourd'hui un bilan de l'application
des lois
depuis depuis 2007 en définitive puisque
on arrive quasiment au terme de la
législature exercice auquel je me suis
livré mercredi dernier au passage vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président
un conseil des ministres est juste à la
sortie du conseil devant la commission
des lois de l'assemblée
mais d'ailleurs la tradition la plus
ancienne de suivi de l'application des
lois appartient aux c'est la même seuil
est c'est vrai c'est bien ce que je vous
dis dès 1971 la première édition de
votre rapport annuel de suivi a fait a
fait ses marques et depuis régulièrement
vous vous livrer à cet exercice et je ne
peux que me réjouir du choix effectué
par la haute assemblée de se doter d'une
commission de contrôle d'application des
lois qui pourra sans pour approfondir la
démarche d'évaluation de la mise en
oeuvre effective des lois et de leurs
applications
je rentrais plus dans le détail d'un
distinction que je fais entre
l'application et l'évaluation sur le
président j'attache d'autant plus de
prix à notre débat aujourd'hui que comme
a bien voulu le relever le président
souligne j'ai souhaité dès mon arrivée
au gouvernement mme impliqué
personnellement dans le traitement de la
question de l'application des lois
pourquoi parce que je suis issu du
parlement et que pendant dix ans en
plein de prison de commission des
affaires économiques à l'assemblée
j'ai trop longtemps on est trop souvent
constaté les retards pris dans l'est
sorti des textes d'application et je me
suis mis dans la tête à l'époque de
faire évoluer la pratique et en 2005
notamment je me permets de vous le
rappeler
j'ai mis au point un mécanisme de
contrôle l'assemblée
l'application des lois avec un
rapporteur l'application des lois
c'était sur le texte sur les territoires
ruraux c'était monsieur coussin c'est le
premier et puis ensuite binôme avec la
majorité l'opposition pour aller car je
considère que la transparence la plus
totale doit être mise en oeuvre pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois est
dès à présent je vous dis oui monsieur
le président pour la transparence et
pour la communication des documents que
vous souhaitez je veillerai pendant que
je serai à cette responsabilité monsieur
carrère je veillerai à faire en sorte
que les documents vous soit transmis
instantanément et bien à partir de ce
binôme ensuite l'article 145 du
règlement de l'assemblée nationale a
concrétisé cette pratique est devenue
maintenant régulière j'en veux pour
preuve la création du comité
d'évaluation et de contrôle des
politiques publiques à l'assemblée
nationale en 2009 et aujourd'hui vous
avez pris l'initiative avec juste raison
de créer une communauté une commission
de contrôle d'évaluation des lois je ne
peux que m'en réjouir
et lorsque je suis arrivé au
gouvernement je me suis dit que cette
action j'avais conduite du côté du
parlement
je pouvais aussi aider mes collègues du
gouvernement à la conduire au
gouvernement est tout d'abord j'ai subi
ici vous avez raison un débat organisé
par groupe rdse je crois à l'époque
c'était début de l'année 2000
2011 oui 2011 et j'avais à l'époque
indiqué qu'il serait préférable que nous
rapprochions nos critères de calcul
d'évaluation et je remercie et les
administrateurs du sénat et vous même
monsieur le président qui avait
travaillé à cette convergence et avoir
la commission des lois il y avait
travaillé avait préparé ce travail avec
nous on avait concrétisé je peux que
m'en réjouir car nous arrivons
maintenant à des modalités de calcul à
des critères qui sont les mêmes non on
va arriver à la date on va arriver la
date et je me suis donc investi dans la
mission de mettre en place un comité de
suivi de l'application des lois des vols
à l'arrivée donc au gouvernement
celui ci a été lancé le 10 mars 2011
et depuis il travaille il travaille à
faire en sorte que les mesures
d'application sorte le plus rapidement
possible il s'appuie tout naturellement
sur le travail remarquable remarquable
j'insiste effectué par le secrétaire
général du gouvernement avec lequel nous
sommes en collaboration il est composé
d'une soixantaine de personnes
correspondant administrative directeur
de cabinet de chacun des ministères
formation élargie ou en formation
restreinte se réunit tous les mois et il
est situé bien sûr il est placé auprès
du ministre et avec le secrétaire
général du gouvernement
nous faisons en sorte de conduire ces
travaux et au passage je vous fais
remarquer qu'un certain nombre des
membres de ce comité sont là présents
autour de moi ici devant et d'autres
encore dans le bureau des ministres
car ils ont tenu à venir participer à ce
débat je les en remercie
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons d'abord
le fait que ce comité de suivi de
l'application des lois existent permet
d'abord au secrétaire général du
gouvernement et à tous ses
fonctionnaires et dans chaque ministère
prépare les mesures d'application des
lois de se sentir plus soutenue et mieux
reconnu dès lors que le politique
effectivement se préoccupe à travers un
ministre et un comité spécifique d'une
manière quotidienne du travail qui est
le leur reconnue c'est le mot et je suis
heureux que cette reconnaissance de ce
travail permis d'enclencher un processus
processus vertueux cela stimule la
sortie des décrets et je voulais dit je
vous le redis aujourd'hui il m'arrive
par exemple de d'un conseil des
ministres de distribuer les ai montré
autre jour des fiches à mes collègues
avant le conseil des ministres en leur
montrant le défi ce qu'ils font le
relevé de décret qui reste à sortir
je leur ai écrit régulièrement à ça
c'est une bonne idée se carrer toutes
les bonnes idées sont à prendre mais je
suis pas sûr d'être dans le cadre des
économies que l'état impose à ses
ministères d'avoir les moyens de sortir
des fiches en couleurs voit que je me
rends sens de l'humour plus de crédit
que le président voilà et ceci est très
positif et je vais donner des résultats
dans quelques instants
1 outre j'ai également nouer un dialogue
avec le conseil d'état
je suis allé à la rencontre du président
sauvez qui m'a reçu et j'ai rencontré
les présidents de section
c'était la première fois qu'un ministre
se déplaçait au conseil d'état pour
discuter avec le conseil d'état
des décrets qui était en stock ou qu'ils
allaient venir et nous avons réussi avec
le présent sauver je tiens à remercier à
établir une constitution de listes de
textes prioritaire pour accélérer
hiérarchisé et accélérer la sortie de
ces décrets
la réunion a donc été très constructive
elle est suivie d'effets très vertueux
d'ailleurs de la part du conseil d'état
alors monsieur le président vous avez
évoqué plusieurs sujets
ayant trait entrer dans le détail mais
appliquer la loi pour le michel il reste
qu'au parlement
c'est d'abord faire en sorte que sortent
les mesures d'application
quelle qu'elle soit quelle sorte et je
suis heureux de pouvoir affirmer devant
vous que tout au long de la législature
le gouvernement s'y est attaché à faire
en sorte de sortir ces mesures la preuve
c'est la circulaire du premier ministre
2008 qui indique et qui fixe comme
objectif pour le gouvernement de rendre
applicable dès loi dans un délai de six
mois après la publication donc on en
revient à ce délai qui est fixé et qui
pour moi en tout cas est incontournable
et qu'on fait en sorte de respecter tant
que faire se peut merci monsieur le
président souligne d'avoir bien voulu
souligner lors de votre conférence de
presse vous avez réitéré aujourd'hui
qu'il y avait une action volontariste du
côté du gouvernement
toute l'équipe autour de moi est
sensible à ce compliment
alors sur la base de ces six mois
suivant la publication de la loi au
passage est un délai que la
jurisprudence administrative qualifie de
raisonnable n'a pas inventé ce délai au
doigt mouillé
ce délai est qualifié de raisonnable
pour l'adoption de décrets d'application
et je suis heureux ce président que nous
soyons mis d'accord sur ce délai et sur
la date
alors c'est vrai que nous sommes mis
d'accord avec vous sur un bilan au 31
décembre de l'année ne discute pas de
cela et je suis heureux que ce bilan
ayant été établie vous êtes arrivé sur
le taux global d'exécution des lois de
toute la législature à 84 % au 31
décembre 2011
je confirme le stack correspond tout à
fait aux taux établi par le comité
d'application des lois que je préside
donc nous sommes d'accord sur ce
résultat au 31 décembre
mais le problème c'est que ce comité est
en action et qui s'arrêtent pas le 31
décembre et continue à travailler et dit
même qui quand il je dirais même dit
continuera à travailler jusqu'au dernier
jour de présence du midi dans la salle
du parlement dans ses fonctions soit si
monsieur carrère a raison pas raison on
verra qui succédera à qui mais au
passage quel que soit le futur bini je
souhaite qu'ils préservent l'existence
de son comité de suivi pour qu'ils
continuer à faire ce travail pourquoi
parce que le travail que nous avons
réalisé avec toute l'équipe qui est ici
présentée cet été à jour du guide du
gouvernement sur l'état général
gouvernement a provoqué une progression
tel que je peux dire que le bilan est
sans précédent
j'insiste alors que le taux
d'application des lois au moment du
lancement de comité suivi était à peu
près à mars 2011 le taux d'application
pour les lois votées de plus de six mois
je répète était autour de 65%
il atteint au 31 janvier 2012
près de 90% du président parce que entre
le 31 décembre à 81 4%
il y a eu ce travail du comité qui va
continuer qui va poursuivre ses travaux
qui fait que nous sommes à 87 2 % au 31
janvier
on continue et on va vous transmettre
l'échiné mais attendaient 87 2% au 31
janvier
je peux dire sans me tromper devant vous
toutes et vous tous que nous arriverons
à plus de 90% à la fin de ce mois ou
autour du 15 mars plus de 90%
je vais me l'expliquer c'est un résultat
qui est inédit
jamais aucun gouvernement n'a fait
autant d'efforts pour rendre applicable
et loi qu'il a fait voter
alors je voudrais pas me livrer à une
comparaison mais je le fais quand même
parce qu'il faut toujours avoir des
curseurs pour comparer à titre de
comparatif à la fin de la 11e
législature l'auto c'était je crois le
gouvernement de monsieur jospin si je ne
trompe pas le taux était de 60 % et à la
fin de la 12e législature président
chirac il était de 70%
il sera au terme du gouvernement de
françois fillon et de l'asie stature
pour laquelle le président sarkozy était
et est président et
et donc été sera j'espère président il
sera de plus de 90% sur le président je
peux pas je ne peux pas je peux pas
pardon constatée en ce résultat avec
toute l'équipe qui a travaillé je peux
pas m'empêcher de vous dire que je suis
heureux de vous dire cela c'est quand
même mieux que 60% et mieux que 70%
constaterez avec moi alors il d'autant
plus mais je vous remercie c'est un
bonheur partagé car il ne veut plus
remarquable qu'il prend bien en compte
l'ensemble des lois s'agit stature vous
avez raison il ya des lois pour lesquels
les décrets sont moins bien sorti que
d'autres y compris celles qui appellent
un très grand nombre de décrets parce
que hpst c'est-à-dire hôpital patients
santé territoires où la loi sur
l'engagement national pour
l'environnement aller de loi sur le
grenelle 1 et grenelle 2 sont des lois
qui implique beaucoup décret alors
pourquoi monsieur assouline pas une
question vous dit le gouvernement
devrait faire des lois et qui comporte
mon article mais j'ai les chiffres là le
grenelle 2 article de départ une
centaine une centaine d'articles
monsieur le président à la sortie du
sénat 257 points pendant sortie du
parlement parce qu'il ya aussi
l'assemblée 257
mais monsieur le président carrère
pourquoi pourquoi il ya de bonnes choses
dans ces articles on peut les partager
le certainement à l'origine de certains
noms je suis sérieux 104 articles du
gouvernement on sort du parlement 257
il faut donc forcément des décrets
d'application sur 257 articles et non
pas sur 104
comprenez que ça nous complique la vie
la modernisation de l'agriculture
c'est une loi j'étais président de la
commission à l'époque à l'assemblée je
l' ai vécu cette loi de manière positive
tellement positive il y avait 24
articles départ la sortie du parlement
96 article alors si vous voulez monsieur
le président souligne que le
gouvernement reste dans un contingent
d'articles raisonnable fait en sorte
avec l'autorité qui est la vôtre dans la
haute assemblée
que l'on évite au sénat notamment on va
s'occuper de l'assemblée de faire en
sorte de doubler voire de tripler le
nombre d'articles et la responsabilité
partagée
elle est autant du gouvernement que du
parlement il s'agit pas de la droite ou
de la gauche et jallet simplement que
quand il ya la passion de sujets que
vous partagez sur tous ces bons ici vous
souhaitez que ce chiffre traduit par un
article de loi est légitime que vous le
vauthier et ça fait des décrets
d'application de plus à sortir alors le
nombre total des mesures monsieur
président solide au 31 janvier au 31
janvier 2012
le nombre total des mesures législatives
pour appliquer l'ensemble des lois
publiées depuis six mois est de 2400 25
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
nombre de total total de mesures qui ont
été prises et de 2115
il nous en reste encore 310 à prendre
cela représente 87 2% je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
et comme je voulais indiqué je vous le
répète le tableau de bord dans le cas de
la transparence vous sera dorénavant
transmis au fur et à mesure que nous le
recevrons à partir je parle à mes
collaborateurs de la semaine prochaine
donc c'est vrai que ce taux atteindra
plus de 90% dans les semaines à venir et
je tiens monsieur présent seul hymne à
votre disposition la liste des 40 décret
à paraître dans les jours qui viennent
et qui sont prochainement noms qui
sortent au conseil d'état on a la liste
xaintrailles très sérieux ou qui sont
contre st signatures contre 5
ministériel dé n'accord 40
vous allez voir et bien encore d'autres
après et c'est bien la première fois
qu'en prise en art public un premier
ministre pourront faire et à la fin de
mandature d'un tel résultat en matière
d'application des lois alors pour
reprendre les termes du président et
pour terminer assouline
un bilan quantitatif ne serait ce qu'en
phone avec un bilan qualitatif
vous avez raison vous avez raison mais
là on est dans deux responsabilités
différentes
de manière assez de manière délibérée
que le bilan d'application des lois
établies par le gouvernement se
concentre sur ce qui est en propre de
son ressort et du mien notamment c'est à
dire l'adoption des décrets et des
mesures d'application
ça c'est notre responsabilité et nous
essayons d'y faire face
l'évaluation de l'application d'une loi
par exemple des moyens dévolus à sa mise
à neuf sites autre chose monsieur le
président je rappelle les termes du
premier alinéa de l'article 24 la
constitution le parlement vote la loi il
contrôler l'action du gouvernement
il évalue les politiques publiques
cogner donc autant l'application de la
loi dans le quantum de deux mesures
d'application qu'il faut sortir pour
qu'elle soit appliquée et notre
responsabilité c'est bien le but de ce
comité la picasse de suite
d'applications démagogie créé autant
l'évaluation de la loi c'est-à-dire la
manière dont elle est appliquée sur le
terrain
et lorsque j'ai lancé ses missions de
contrôle de l'exécution des lois à
l'époque quand j'étais à l'assemblée je
me suis rendu compte que pour la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture dans deux
départements
ce site pas lesquelles les services de
l'état apie qui la loi de manière
différente
pourquoi ça c'est d'évaluation et cette
évaluation
pardon de vous le dire aussi brutalement
c'est le travail du parlement et c'est
votre travail monsieur le président on a
suffisamment discuté je sais que vous
êtes bien d'accord pour vous y engager
vous avez dit vous-même effectivité de
la loi appliquée de telle ou telle
manière dans les différents quartiers ou
territoires vous avez raison on est en
plein dans l'évaluation et ça ce n'est
pas le travail c'est aussi le travail du
gouvernement bien sûr mais ce n'est pas
le travail auquel moi je veux je dois je
suis responsable dont je suis
responsable pardon c'est à dire les
mesures d'application alors les voies de
progrès il est indéniable que l'aspect
quantitatif de l'application des lois
est désormais sous un contrôle efficace
c'est pour ça que je forme le voeu que
le prochain gouvernement quel qu'il soit
un script c'est ravaux de la continuité
et que ce comité que j'ai créé perdure
je veux croire que la discipline à
laquelle nous sommes astreints vaudra
obligation pour les prochains
gouvernements à faire aussi bien et
peut-être mieux parce que plus de 90%
c'est beaucoup
mais c'est pas 100% donc bon courage
ce qui constitue déjà je crois un
progrès énorme et nul n'est parfait
monsieur le président souligne et je
mesure la difficulté qu'il y a de passer
à 93 94 jusqu'aux 100 % nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance à suivre
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
public sénat avec comme invité ce soir
henri guaino conseiller spécial du
président nicolas sarkozy bonne soirée à
tous